débat ce soir sur l'environnement et la
relance économique avec charles
milliards pdg de la fédération des
chambres de commerce du québec et
patrick bonnet responsable de la
campagne climat énergie de greenpeace à
vous de bonsoir bonsoir on va parler
avec vous du projet de loi
66 qui veut accélérer 181 projets
d'infrastructure qui a été présenté par
la ministre sont nés à lebel cette
semaine et qui prévoit et je cite
l'application de mesures d'accélération
en matière d'environnement
charles milliards est-ce que vous pensez
qu'ici on arrive à conjuguer la relance
économique et la protection
d'environnement
excellente question je pense que le
projet de loi 61 vient profiter durant
l'été pour devenir donc le projet doit
66 qui on vient vraiment favoriser
l'accélération projets d'infrastructure
sans rogner sur l'intégrité un qui était
une des grandes préoccupations de
plusieurs personnes en juin dernier et
sur l'environnement mais évidemment le
projet doit être effectif qui j'espère
qu'on pourra l'en consultations
parlementaires pour en particules pour
en discuter en des consultations
particulières mais pour savoir quand
même que les amendes des sanctions les
vérifications sont prévus à la loi sur
la qualité de l'environnement ne change
pas donc on vient accélérer certains
délais administratifs a surpris s'il met
donc c'est acceptable pour vous il ça va
dans le bon sens patrick bonneil vous en
pensez quoi du côté greenpeace et sept
autres organisations nationales dans
l'environnement nous sommes rapidement
sorti en disant qu'on est encore une
fois et qui est malheureusement parce
que le projet de loi essentiellement
propose un affaiblissement au niveau des
exigences environnementales même chose
au niveau des consultations publiques
même chose au niveau de la loi d'accès à
l'information donc évidemment va
continuer l'analyse on espère que le
gouvernement est prêt à bonifier son
projet de loi parce que pour l'instant
malheureusement il semble opposer
environnement et économie encore une
fois est en recul des monstres bah oui
en effet il ya aucune démonstration qui
a été fait qu'il y a pour ce type de
projet la nécessité d'accélérer le
processus environnementale à travers un
affaiblissement
s'il ya un manque de ressources par
exemple au sein du ministère pour être
en mesure de mener à terme rapidement
les évaluations environnementales
il faut augmenter les ressources qu'il
faut au moins telle personne
elle doit s que les évaluations
environnementale actuelle freine la
relance comme le laisse un peu entendre
le gouvernement pense pas qu'il faut il
faut réunir encore une fois sur les
exigences environnementales qu'on a au
québec on perd on peut être fier milieux
de l'environnement qu'on a mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il ya des délais
administratifs dans le processus qui
peuvent être accéléré alors dans le
chaos actuel les objectifs je pense ne
sont pas les objectifs environnementaux
ne sont pas modifiées on va pouvoir
permettre à certains projets de démarrer
et de fournir des analyses en cours mais
ça changera pas la reddition de comptes
qui pourrait d'ailleurs que tu as tes
lectures davantage une mesure des
impacts sociaux je jure concept dont on
va le dire comme sur parlementaire
encore une fois mais les objectifs des
annonces des sanctions ne change pas
donc faut quand même reconnaître qu'il
ya une volonté du gouvernement de
protéger l'environnement faut pas
glisser trop non plus non moi je
comprends puis je vais entendre patrick
bonnet la tue mais ali plus rapidement
nécessairement il faut faire des choix
dans ce qu'on évalue pensez pas nous on
pense qu'on a un système d'évaluation
environnementale au québec qui vient de
subir une réforme d'ailleurs et là ce
qui est proposé c'est un affaiblissement
et on voit une tendance vers un
glissement justement d'un
affaiblissement de ses consultations
publiques là qui sont importants de ces
évaluations et les exigences
environnementales
encore une fois si on prend par exemple
l'exemple du système de santé où il y
avait des problèmes avec la pandémie il
y en a encore il ya eu un ajout de
ressources les entrepries dix mille
personnes qui ont été ajoutés et ont pas
eu un affaiblissement des standards de
qualité au niveau de la santé
on s'attend à avoir le même niveau
d'exigence et de professionnalisme de la
part du gouvernement et ce n'est pas ce
que ce projet de loi propose selon notre
analyse kiwi et et son tour préliminaire
1 mais quand même on a déjà vu neiger ce
genre de projet pour nous est inquiétant
est ce que dans les 181 projets
d'infrastructure est ce que vous pensez
qu'on a sur ce qu'on peut appeler une
relance verte de l'économie
une petite réponse de chacun monsieur
charles milliards da à écouter je
constate que le projet de loi 60 6
comparativement la première version 61
et
les projets une liste de projets qui est
fermé clavel hamas et oui donc on pourra
ajouter des projets alors que monsieur
dubé en juin avait mentionné qu on
pourrait ajouter des projets si s'ils
avaient un intérêt ou qu'ils avaient des
propositions qui était intéressante
donc effectivement moi je pense que
plusieurs projets là dedans qui vont
favoriser une relance verte
mais je tiens à dire que y'a il ya des
améliorations qui peuvent être apportées
donc comme je le mentionnais sur entre
autres la question du plus bas
soumissionnaire conforme dans l'octroi
des contrats publics ont aimé cette 7e
mention là d'un projet doit 61 et ce
serait important que rapidement dans les
règlements on puisse enfin dire aux
fournisseurs de l'état québécois on veut
miser sur des facteurs de développement
durable de qualité d' expertise
d'innovation c'est une autre façon
d'encourager l'environnement je suis
d'accord sur le fait que ce projet de
loi ne permet pas de rêver d'une relance
verte une relance juste au québec c'est
essentiellement une accélération dans
une vision de développement relativement
traditionnels ce qu'on voit au niveau
international ce soit au niveau du fmi
et de l'osce et de l'onu les grands
investisseurs qui prône une relance va
être de véritables investissements qui
permettrait aux états de ces lignes est
entre autres avec les objectifs de la
carte de paris je me rappelle c'est la
science dit qu'il faut est auprès de la
carboneutralité en 2050 donc c'est un
virage majeur dans l'ensemble des
secteurs et évidemment le gouvernement
propose des traces de doigts quelques
projets par exemple de transport
collectif mais encore beaucoup de
projets de transport routier il ya peu
d'habitations dit par exemple et
écoénergétiques et ce qui doit falloir
c'est qu' un plan d'action de lutte
contre les changements climatiques ou
d'économie verte qui arrivent rapidement
cet automne pour venir compléter ce
projet qui selon mme g incomplet pour
parler de relancer ce qui est au coeur
souvent d'évaluation environnementale au
québec c'est le bape le bureau
d'audiences publiques en environnement y
en a un bac présentement sur le projet
énergie saguenay de gnl québec êtes vous
favorable à ce projet là charles médias
et la fccq
écoutez on est dans un débat pas certain
qu'en trois minutes on va pouvoir
s'entendre sur ce dossier là mais je
pense que certains fai qui parle quand
même quand on parle
quand on parle du projet énergie
saguenay j'ai juste mentionné qu'on
parle d'un investissement de 9 milliards
de dollars
6500 employés lors de la construction et
c'est quand même il faut dire peut-être
que mon collègue n'appréciera pas mais
que c'est quand même mon projet qu'on
projette de construire une usine qui
serait à la plus faible émission en
terme en terme d' usine donc au monde
dans un contexte où on a un candidat à
la présidentielle américaine de l'autre
côté de la frontière
quelque 40 à 45% d'intentions de vote
qui veut repartir l'industrie du charbon
alors le charbon et le mazout j'espère
que vous voyez sur comme une ligne et
une énergie de transition et gnl le
présente comme ça patrick bonin vous
étiez à saguenay cette semaine
comment comment vous avez trouvé ça
est-ce que ce bateau fait un bon travail
malheureusement on a eu plusieurs grands
enjeux cette semaine avec le bape entre
autres l'absence d'experts indépendants
de l'entreprise je parle de d'experts
indépendants des gouvernements pour nous
parler justement la question des
changements climatiques comment ce
projet leur sincère dans des scénarios
qui nous permettrait de respecter
l'accord de paris il n'y avait personne
personne pour confronter l'entreprise
sur ses prétentions de marché économique
de débouchés donc c'est pour nous
malheureusement un travail qui a été
relativement bas cliquons bâtiment à ce
à quoi on certain normalement du bas sur
le sur la question est ce que c'est un
projet qui s'insère dans une relance
verte oui mais clairement pour nous je
vous rappelle la carboneutralité en 2050
c'est loin d'être un projet qui
permettrait ça c'est un projet qui
augmenterait massivement la production
de gaz non conventionnels dans l'ouest
canadien produit à part tuer à partir de
fracturation hydraulique et qu'ils
enverraient se gardent un petit peu
partout sur la planète
possiblement évidemment compétitionner
les énergies renouvelables sans aucune
garantie de 3 ans placé du charbon ou
même d'apporter des gains sur le charbon
quand on parle de gaz informationnel
alors il y aura une autre semaine pour
présenter des mémoires un peu plus tard
au mois d'octobre on va continuer de
suivre le dossier d'énergie saguenay
charles milliards patrick bonnet merci
beaucoup merci ça vaut